während ich im krankenhaus war ist die
dame verstorben und das ist für mich ja
ich könnte also mit dem grund ich könnte
ihren job nicht machen
[Musik]
dunja hayali 2020 es geht wieder los das
ist heute der erste drehen einem
altenheim und es ist für mich persönlich
eine herausforderung weil meine eltern
eben selber auch lange in einem
altenheim gelebt haben das ist der grund
warum ich das thema immer und immer und
immer und immer wieder auf dem tisch
wurde
ich bin sehr gespannt auf die
geschichten von heute
[Musik]
damit sind wir bestens vorbereitet für
den tag genau denn meine medikamente
[Musik]
ok dann würde ich sagen halte ich sie
nicht länger auf hilfe aber natürlich
mit nämlich auch nützlich machen
ich will sie ja nicht von ihrer arbeit
anfallen
[Musik]
ich hänge sehr an meine bewohner und
herzlich wieder gekommen bin
es war sehr schwierig für mich die
menschen nicht mehr ist zu sehen die ich
immer gesehen habe und wir sind nach mal
da sind und wir sind teilweise
gleichzeitig interessiert worden so
sagen wir hatten wir waren gleichzeitig
krank und als ich wieder gekommen
wahnsinnig dass das hat mir sehr
wehgetan also das tut heute noch wie wir
hier ein zimmer vorbeigehen das zimmer
steht leer und das tut einfach weh man
kann manchmal das nicht beschreiben
[Musik]
zuvor wildungen blumen nur jetzt kommt
ja jetzt jetzt kommen die tabletten ein
ja lassen weil hier die grenzen
haben sie gut geschlagen mit problemen
herum armen wir uns immer ja also und
jetzt ist nicht möglich sind manchmal
sagt sie ich würde sie gerne so drücken
oder wir machen uns einfach ein herzchen
luft herzchen oder so wir haben sehr da
ist es ja machen uns ein herz von weiten
machen wir uns ein herz da gibt es ist
wirklich einen schatz also so stelle ich
mir eine pflegekraft vor die brennt für
diesen beruf das ist natürlich schon
wahnsinn du arbeitest hier hat irgendwie
die verantwortung für ganz viele
bewohner bewohnerinnen dann erkrankte
selbst text noch deine tochter an weiß
dass deine mutter in der türkei schwer
krank ist und hat trotzdem ein monster
herz ein strahlen in den augen und so
eine luft lust auf diesen job das ist
das ist für mich jetzt sehr emotional
ich habe mir dieses thema jetzt nicht
gerechnet
hier ist eine dame verstörung nicht sehr
eingerissen hat also sehr eng war und
waren sie denn hier sind gleichzeitig
krank geworden fasst sie waren in
quarantäne als genau während ich im
krankenhaus war ist die dame verstorben
und das ist für mich dieses mal ich bin
jetzt nach seit dem vierten fünften bin
ich hier das bin ich das erste mal hier
ich geh weg vorbei ja genau für mich ist
es natürlich hier ja ich könnte also mit
dem grund ich könnte ihr job nicht
machen
die tochter durfte nicht hier sein
leider das lesezelt weiß natürlich nicht
möglich also wirklich dass ich sie nicht
das sind also jeder der kein kaltes herz
hat das ist glaube ich mit das
schlimmste einen geliebten menschen eben
alleine gehen lassen zu müssen dass man
auch nicht nur einen abschied nehmen
kann dass das ja auch das seminar ich
glaube was man echt nicht unterschätzen
darf ist die emotionale belastung auch
für die pfleger und pflegerinnen also
dass sie hier permanent sich
verabschieden müssen dass sie vielleicht
beim abschied seien gar nicht dabei sein
konnten
die angst vor einer erneuten
möglicherweise ja ansteckung oder was
auch immer
[Musik]
und noch ein paar infos dann ist jeder
herne zu spät
wahnsinn wahnsinn
ich liebe meinen job dachte sich solche
menschen kennenlernen drauf und solche
geschichten erleben darf dafür liebe ich
diesen job
[Musik]
es ist nicht so dass man sich überlegt
haben wir drehen mal in dem wo auch
immer und dann fährt man da hin und sagt
hallo da sind wir sondern im vorfeld
werden natürlich gespräche gefühlt man
fragt schon mal ist das ok damit ist und
das abfragen oder wenn wir das und das
drehen was geht und was geht nicht das
ist also nicht gestellt oder gefaked
sondern man versucht so ein bisschen den
rahmen darzustellen damit unsere
protagonisten auch wissen worauf sie
sich da einlassen und damit es einfach
keine bösen überraschungen oder sowas
gibt deswegen bespricht man das noch mal
das große problem war eigentlich dass es
am anfang keine masken gab keine
geeigneten ffp zwei masken und unsere
zentrale die hat dort sehr viel arbeit
geleistet die hat sehr sehr umfassend
recherchiert und hygieneprodukte
angefragt und in großen mengen auf
gekauft so dass wir dann zum glück in
der lage waren dass wir ausreichend
masken hatten
es ist allerdings nicht so dass man
jetzt sagen könnte dann ist ja alles
toll sondern es geht weiter es waren
keine ausreichenden schutz kittel dar
und zurzeit werden die handschuhe knapp
also so einfache dinge sind noch immer
und tagtäglich das problem das ist zu
all den herausforderungen die sie eh
schon im normalzustand leisten müssen
und wo viele schon überlastet sind jetzt
auch noch das also ich meine kann das so
weitergehen
eine rhetorische frage nein nein muss
man so sagen also ich glaube schon dass
viele unserer mitarbeiter gerade in
dieser zeit absolut eigentlich über ihre
belastungsgrenze hinaus gegangen sind
[Musik]
es ist so krass glaube ich für die
menschen die hier arbeiten die hier
wohnen und natürlich auch für die die
das alles zu verantworten haben und
organisieren und was sie alles im kopf
haben müssen und dann hast du plötzlich
doch infizierte obwohl die möglich geben
hast du hast du den frust der
angehörigen
du bist selber gefrustet und du weißt
irgendwie nicht wann hört es eigentlich
auf und wird es mal wieder besser und
dann haben wir jetzt macht man jetzt
aber keine handschuhe und dann denkt man
doch nur corona du bist ein arschloch
[Musik]
hier und heute hier sein zu dürfen nicht
mit einem menschen zu unterhalten
bestätigt mich noch mal in meine
anerkennung und wertschätzung die ich
für all die pfleger und pflegerinnen
habe in den verschiedensten bereichen
einfach nochmal und steigt noch mal ins
unermessliche
und es ist für mich persönlich eine
herausforderung bei meiner eltern eben
selber auch lange in einem altenheim
gelebt haben
dass leute hier einfach mit herzblut
dabei bleiben und nicht sagen wisst ihr
was ich habe die schnauze voll
finde ich so so großartig aber ich muss
schnell für mich persönlich ist das ein
schwerer werden schon auch viele
erinnerungen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir brauchen mehr personal mehr seit die
leute sie haben es verdient
ich möchte gerne wenn ich feierabend
habe ich möchte einfach zufrieden nach
hause geht es gen jahre unsere jahre und
20 jahre in der schule aber es ändert
sich nicht ja wie gesagt der der sich
das mit dem leben ausgedacht hat das mit
dem tod nicht gut überlegt und corinna
zeiten zählt dieser satz doppelt und
einfach und auf der anderen seite können
wir echt dankbar sein dass wir überhaupt
irgendwie menschen haben die sich um
kranke um alte menschen kümmern nicht
nur während sondern auch während meiner
zeit und deswegen ist dieses thema
pflege so immens wichtig
[Musik]